The year is 2019. I was a bright-eyed youth going
into my second year of college, and a couple high
school friends I used to play Magic with moved
within walking distance of where I lived. We were
all in one place once again, but none of us had
played much Magic recently—my friends each had a
single EDH deck they’d built in high school,
and I didn’t even have that, having recently
lost the mono-black removal pile I played with in
high school in a move. So what was the best way
to play Magic under these circumstances and on a
broke college student budget? Revamp our old decks
and/or build new ones to match them in power? We
pondered this question until noticing a guild die
that had come in a D&D dice set my friend Connor
had bought. This die spawned an idea—what if,
rather than building one or two new decks each, we
instead built a low-cost deck for each guild and
rolled randomly to figure out what deck we’d play
with in a given game? This would allow us to play
a variety of different decks without straining
our meager budgets. Thus began the $25 deck pool.
The deckbuilding began in an interesting place.
Though I knew the Sheoldred deck of my youth had
problems, I was still a black player wanting to do
black player things, so I opted to build an Orzhov
control deck. Putting Kambal in the command zone
offered a great way to keep the deck’s life total
up while chipping away at opposing life totals,
and allowed the rest of the deck to focus on
removal, draw, and various lifegain-related combos
rather than trying to develop beaters. Likewise,
my friend Hans built a pretty brutal Azorius
control list with Noyan Dar in the command zone,
and the fact that the pool began with two control
decks is a factor that shouldn’t be overlooked.
As other decks got fleshed out, this influence
can be seen—of the pool’s five midrange decks,
three were some form of aristocrats, and another
was a land-focused deck that didn’t rely on
keeping nonland permanents in play. The pool
also ended up containing a few more explosive,
combo-oriented decks, and these were likewise
well-suited to handle control, consisting of a
graveyard-centric artifacts deck, a big mana deck,
and a deck with a number of its own counterspells.
Finally, we have what ended up being the
hardest color combination to build a $25 deck
for—Dimir. For my first attempt, I opted for an
artifact tokens list with Rona as the commander,
a midrange deck that could hopefully be flexible
enough to survive in a wide range of scenarios.
So this was the first pool we had, and we played
about 30 games with it before going back to make
major changes. So, how did these decks pan
out? In a word—interestingly. I kept data
on all the games, and the Orzhov deck garnered
an eye-watering 54% winrate, its potent mixture
of lifegain, suppressive elements, and explosive
combos proving too much for most opposing decks.
Among the other decks, winrates varied from 30%
all the way down to 0%, and as the 0 of the group,
the Niv-Mizzet combo deck got switched out for
an artifact-oriented combo deck that uses its
commander, Jhoira, to draw into combo pieces.
In addition to these wide power differences,
a lot of the decks just felt kinda flat and
lifeless, generic midrange decks doing generic
midrange things. For this reason, the Selesnya
midrange deck and the Tatyova lands deck ended
up getting swapped out for a cats aggro deck
and a Vannifar toolbox deck, both decks that
would hopefully bring a bit more zing to the
pool than their predecessors had. And finally,
the Dimir Rona deck unfortunately just did not
work, and looking at the old decklist I can see
why—it was an unfocused mishmash of vaguely
artifact-oriented stuff, and it mostly ended
up feeling toothless above all else. I actually
retuned the deck to be a proliferate deck about
halfway through this period of 30 games, and
that was decidedly not an improvement for it. So,
it was at this point where I scrapped the deck and
followed an idea from my friend Connor to rebuild
it as a Lasav deck, a sort of graveyard-based
combo deck that would use its commander to swing
big with infect through a card called Vector
Asp. With that, a commander swap for Azorius,
and some tuning to all decks, we were
ready to try out another round of games.
After playing another 30 games with the updated
pool, the changes seemed to be working out pretty
well overall. There was a more even spread
among the winrates, and the new combo decks
were working out just fine. Lazav was sitting
comfortably mid-pack in terms of winrate,
its mixture of controlling and combo elements able
to pull through wins often enough. Intriguingly,
Orzhov won literally none of its 11 games within
this period, mostly due to players pressuring it
down first in most of its games. However, its
place of dominance was taken by a different
deck—cats. Commanding a 42% winrate, the cats
deck ended up being a truly ruthless aggro deck,
with the deck’s commander-pumped cats putting on
heavy pressure as early as turn 2. The deck was
also able to fit in enough draw to grind into
the lategame, and this one-two punch was too
much for a lot of the slower decks in the pool.
With strong performances from some faster decks,
the Golgari and Rakdos aristocrats decks
were deemed a bit too slow and bland,
and ended up getting swapped out for
two more aggressive, dynamic decks:
a Grismold tokens deck and a discard deck
with Malfegor as the commander. Additionally,
in the wake of cats making a large splash
within the pool, several slower decks were
modified to have additional lifegain, board
wipes, and creatures to block with. Within
these 10 decks a meaningful metagame had been
developed, a metagame where lacking ways to hold
off creature-based aggression was something
that would cause a deck to win fewer games.
The next period with these ten decks is
interesting because of just how long it
lasted with no major alterations to the deck
pool. Though this period lasted just under 6
months of real world time, there happened to
be some societal factors that hindered other
forms of socialization, so we ended up playing
86 games in that time frame. This fact itself
indicates that this pool was actually pretty good,
both in terms of deck balance and in terms of how
the decks felt. This is also the first time I
had a big enough sample size to consider the
stats halfway reliable, and balance-wise, the
decks ended up grouping into three clusters in
terms of winrate. The most powerful deck deck in
this period was the Simic toolbox midrange deck,
winning a third of its games, and this is likely
because it’s just a very well-rounded deck. It was
able to keep up a moderately-above-average winrate
after the pool’s metagame had been figured out,
as opposed to the Orzhov and Selesnya decks which
had each had their moments of extreme dominance
before eventually being adapted to by other decks.
Speaking of those, the next cluster contained five
decks that all had a high 20s win percentage:
the Orzhov control deck, the Selesnya cats deck,
the Golgari Grismold deck, the Azorius control
deck, and the Gruul big mana deck. The lowest
cluster was in the high teens—decidedly not a
terrible winrate, I feel it should be noted, but
not a great one either—and this group contained
the Boros eggs deck, the Rakdos discard deck,
and the two combo decks. Despite holding
up decently in the previous round of games,
both combo decks put on a pretty lackluster
performance in these 86 games, and I chalk this
up to two factors. For one, their play patterns
got figured out—for the Lazav deck, this meant
that people could know roughly how quickly the
deck would achieve its combo, and also what weak
points should be targeted when in order to disrupt
the deck. The other factor is that the pool had
become significantly more aggressive as the number
of aggro decks increased and as the slower decks
added more creatures to stave off pressure. And
ultimately, the Lasav deck’s biggest weakness
is that it simply didn’t have the blockers to
keep away pressure for long enough to combo.
So, what did we decide to do with this pool?
Well, I factored in placement in games into the
calculation for purposes of deciding which decks
weren’t working, and my reasoning for this is that
a deck that doesn’t win much but is durable enough
to stick around awhile is more fun than a deck
that doesn’t win much and also gets knocked out
first each round. The Radkos discard deck, and to
a lesser extent the Boros eggs deck, was grindy
and interactive enough to stay alive, whereas
the Dimir and Izzet decks had a tendency to get
knocked out first, especially the Lasav deck. So,
after three different iterations of slower Dimir
decks being tried out, the Dimir Lasav deck was
replaced with a rogue-based aggro deck with Sygg,
River Cutthroat as the commander. It had become
what it had tried and failed to survive against.
With this Sygg deck and a new Izzet spellslinger
deck, the pool entered its finished state. We’ve
actually only played about 25 games with the pool
since these early 2021 updates, and this is for
the simple reason that we each found things to do
with our lives aside from sitting inside playing
commander games. Don’t get me wrong, I’m glad we
did this final update, and the Sygg deck I built
for it is one that I still occasionally pull out
to this day, but most of these decks have probably
seen less than 10 games in the past two years. The
fervor we had for building, tracking, and updating
these decks was greatly fueled by the fact that it
basically all took place during 2020 and the first
half of 2021. And the funny thing is, the fact
that I had this major period of EDH deckbuilding
during my college years almost certainly
contributed to my decision to begin making videos
about the format. So in a sense, Salubrious Snail
is brought to you by the Covid-19 pandemic.
Garbage sponsor honestly, would not recommend.
So, what is there to take away from this
little fable I’ve weaved for you? Well,
to start with I would say that if you’re
tempted to make your own pool of decks,
do it! It’s a super fun process, and the creation
of a little metagame within these is neat. In this
video I probably made this process seem highly
analytical, but realistically we mostly just went
with what we felt like, with the constraint of two
rules—decks should be a consistent power level,
and decks should do something unique that other
decks need to consider, both during games and
during the deckbuilding process. There are a
handful of somewhat more generic decks in this
pool such as Simic, Dimir, and Izzet, but the
other 7 are extremely evocative and put forth a
specific threat that requires consideration. The
Rakdos deck tries to render the table hellbent
by turn 6, the Gruul deck inevitably explodes
out of control if it stays alive long enough,
the Azorius deck is a truly oppressive control
deck, the Grismold deck injects an aggressive
dose of voltron into the pool, and the Orzhov
deck can dominate late games with its mixture
of board wipes and lifegain-based combos. I dug
around some old discord messages while scripting
for this video, and the specificity of the
decks in this pool can be seen in how me,
Hans, and the other players would talk about the
decks. Can this survive X, can this pressure Y,
does this fold to Z? If these decks were all
generic midrange decks, this thought process
would be wholly unnecessary, but since these
decks are so punchy and evocative in what they do,
they demand consideration. So I guess what
I’m saying here is basically just that if
you build a set of decks like this, don’t let any
of them be overly weak or overly boring, and have
the courage to be able to dismantle a deck you
like if it ends up being one of these things.
As a final point, this process of building decks
formulated a lot my understanding of the commander
format, and when I started playing with decks
outside this pool in the first half of 2023,
I had kind of a rude awakening where
most of the games I played were way less
dynamic and interesting than the games
with these $25 decks. My first Magic:
the Gathering video was partially inspired by
this, this experience of playing against bland,
formulaic midrange decks without enough
interaction to make for a dynamic game. And
while I’ve had plenty more interesting games since
then, I try to keep the mindset that I had when
building those $25 decks, which is to say, try
to present a specific problem for your opponents,
and be prepared for if your opponents present
a problem for you. To me, multiplayer games are
more fun when people have to think about their
opponents, rather than when everybody is just
racing engines against each other like we’re
all playing some kind of second-rate Eurogame.
Thanks for watching! I linked a folder in the
description that contains the final versions
of all 10 of these decks, though some cards have
gone up in price in the past few years. I’m also
releasing an endnote over on my Patreon where
I discuss the Orzhov deck in a bit more detail,
so if that interests you you can head on
over there and throw some money at me.